it's at this precise moment that a harsh
reality finally sets in
for all of my wise cracking I'm actually
a little scared you can feel the breeze
but it's cozy
wall okay it's a nice warm breeze from
the Arctic Circle
dozen miles north of here
this is probably going to suck
I'm a total wimp around this stuff and
uh I wanted to ask you
why
why do this because you can
okay
weirdo a good question it's actually a
great question why do you do this friend
of mine got me to try it once and I came
out I don't drink alcohol but I came out
so high on life that I did I I was
amazed yeah I think for me at least I
think it's about stepping out of my
comfort zone and when we go in the sea
then it is difficult and it's always a
challenge even though Makkah and I are
very used to going to see now and we go
three times a week it's always a bit of
a challenge but then you think I am
doing this I am going to do it and
there's nothing changing that I'm here
I'm doing it
then you can transfer that onto so many
other things in life that are difficult
or challenging
[Music]
everyone's ready
the main task is to surrender to the
coast
welcome to students
and we're breathing
and the second was to say to your body
I'm okay
I know for me I have literally have been
diagnosed with an anxiety disorder like
I am a highly anxious person and there's
work that I do on a daily basis that
helps bring me kind of to vaguely within
normal so it was for me I had a lot of
resistance like oh I can't believe I
have to do this it's early in the
morning it's cold outside but I found it
so
uh uplifting
I feel invigorated in a in a really new
and positive way and honestly it didn't
feel that cold all this ocean tipping is
also about just letting go and it's
funny because in Iceland it gets dark in
the winter and often we have bad weather
and you can you can complain about the
weather all the time if you want but
when you do ocean dipping the whole year
you don't even notice that it gets dark
you don't even notice that the weather
is bad it just does not matter
are you two
happier than when you started this 15
years ago
I just I could imagine life without
going in the sea every week and not just
happier because it's like a word and
then it says then you think what does it
mean it means that you are healthy it
means that you can cut through
difficulties it means that you are able
to
enjoy life
just the way you are and nothing else
matters
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you